after several guests had complained
about the water quality the hotel had
sent a worker up to inspect the water
tanks the body of a young woman was
found in one of them o clock okay it's
another episode yeah what episode is
this anyway 83 god damn you say that
every week I know when you get old man a
week it doesn't take long man just one
right after the other after the other
close me closer to the grave soon you
don't know and what's it this show is so
cheerful
yeah we're recording on a Friday we're
not going out tonight so we're just
gonna drink in here yeah I think we're
drinking right now so we may get drunker
oh yeah do that because usually we
record these in the afternoon yeah you
know that like usually a day or two
before I put them up but I kind of
wanted to get out of the way cuz we have
a lot of stuff going on this weekend and
I was like well I don't really have much
time to record it so Friday night we're
gonna record it Friday night we're not
going anyplace yeah so we just bought a
big huge thing of rum and yeah we went
mad needs more rum and we were passing
by Sam's Anna Simon go there and get
some booze and I was gonna get some
Bacardi and right next to the head that
members mark yes is in the same bottle
and the woman that worked there I said
is that good good oh yeah I can't tell
it from from go cardi and it looked to
be the same bottle they probably buy it
from the same distillery they exit so I
bought it man as good as like $12 right
here I think I'll tell the difference
between that over now it's good I got a
nice mojito and Jenny's got a double
Roman toga that's right yeah and I'm
drinking this mojito out of a damn mason
jar cuz you're classy is the socket
class this class he's like redneck class
rednecks rednecks judge class by size
yeah it is yeah the bigger it is the
more classic head
I'm seriously I keep threatening to do
this but I was like one year for your
birthday or for Christmas I'm totally
getting you those mason jars with like
the champagne glass they're not free
though well they could we're free
they're even classic okay could be if I
went in Walmart and was really sneaky
okay we got to do the show is to show
all right so let's do our usual shout
outs I booked the faceless villain
obviously still out if you haven't got
one yet get one I think bill take a nap
I think I only I might not have any free
audio codes laughs oh good I might have
one but I'm kind of doubting it unseen
hand is still slamming in this well yeah
that still sells to actually all my
books still sell good ones are still
going faceless villain volume two I
haven't had a chance to work on it this
year I'm actually on chapter 8 she's
doing a lot of contract work for a
company to making packaging and stuff
recently so she's real busy
yeah so yeah that's all it is and you
know once that kind of we can't send up
a little bit she can't pass up those
yeah that's still what pays most of my
bills on really so you know and it's
kind of this is my main client I do a
lot of their packaging work and some so
I've been doing that but you know I work
on it whenever I get a chance to work on
it and I'm shooting for having it out by
either before summer or early summer
like June or something like that and
because I want to have both of them out
I want to have both volumes out I would
have liked to out by June and then
buying three out by the end of the year
yeah I can have the trilogy oh we passed
2,000 subscribers on YouTube yeah that's
pretty good that seems like we're
getting like maybe close to 15 of them a
day yeah that's good maybe it seems like
it's speeding up although I think our
footprints a little bit bigger but you
guys you know our our regulars like
share subscribe help us grow yeah well
they've already subscribed yes you
haven't even drank that much don't get
like that already getting high above
this Michael I have my mind gets clearer
though sometimes as I drink it's like I
focus okay let's go let's go stream with
um also check out our latest movie
review which was Saturn 3 they forgotten
1980 sci-fi flick starring Kirk Douglas
yeah
naked ass yeah as well as Farrah Fawcett
who was very young and not very well
known at that stakeout it's still a cool
flick I like it
and um you guys can watch it for free
it's on yeah - I mean it's like I said
it's not as good as the blu-ray the blue
weight transfers also and I think I
forgot to mention this on our
retrospective but you can totally get to
watch a naked Kirk Douglas trying to
kill Harvey Keitel yeah I fightin butt
ass naked it's a good movie it's kind of
like alien and blade runner's cheaper
younger brother that's a good way of
putting it yeah it's in the same
universe yeah it's kind of the same
actually I think I would like that
someone should reboot that so it was so
a soldier with the crustle that was also
in the same universe people don't know
that
did I haven't seen that movie I'll buy
it okay soldier it's not that great but
it does have oh I remember I don't recap
them yet bring in ten I'll do it yeah
it's got Brussels and I know I've seen
parts of Russell's like a replicant
soldier kinda like Roy batty okay fair
enough and also just a reminder to check
out our patreon page if you haven't
already which is patreon.com slash 13
o'clock or if you don't like patreon I
would like to give a one-time donation
through PayPal then you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account also thank
you and hi to our newest patron Tara
Tara Dee we also we already have a Tara
em but Tara D wish you know we actually
know her yes and yes she lives here yeah
cool I mean I guess she still lives in
the area I haven't seen her out in a
while but yeah so we so we know her and
she loves our show yeah she's a rat a
chick yeah she's awesome Johnny [ __ ]
case yeah from shake case [ __ ] case
enema he loves crustle I know yeah he's
got a man crush on crustle - it's a
universal phenomena it's yeah it's a
dude seriously dude thing oh I recognize
the essential Buddhist trying to you
know enter into the crustle sphere I
guess so okay well you and Johnny [ __ ] k
so I know he's from England yeah
he understands the crustless told you
it's universal the cross the spear is
universal okay so that's all the
shoutouts we have note okay now before
we get into our today we're doing kind
of a creepy sort of unsolved mysteries
type of yeah this is a woman because
we've had more than one request to do
ELISA Lam yeah so we're gonna do that on
the second segment and also I wanted
kind of another creepy mystery that I
kind of find interesting even though I'm
sure that there's you know I'm sure that
there's probably a completely rational
explanation the Flannan Isles lighthouse
keeper's yeah so we'll get into that
first but before we do that yeah news
let's do our news story is this news
time now here's a little news story
that's been circulating all over the
place lately and this actually kind of
amuses the [ __ ] out of me okay you know
those little you know your little
personal assistants your you know your
Siri on your iPhone and your yeah
okay so Amazon has the one that's Alexa
yeah and you know you've seen the
commercials you can ask it to do
whatever well evidently you can ask you
to do whatever
well what would you do it are yeah
apparently several people have been
reporting that their little Alexa in
their house will laugh for no reason oh
[ __ ] like can you imagine Oh creepy that
would be you're just kind of chilling in
your house or whatever and all of a
sudden like someone's laughing and yeah
I wouldn't like that I wouldn't like
that at all either most of the people
that have reported this there it's been
all over Twitter it's gonna lever reddit
like people that have them and they're
saying that that they're not even asking
it anything but it just suddenly starts
just laughing the blue that's turn it on
that's what I hear no I don't play and
sometimes it says it's in response to
unrelated questions one of the and this
one article that I was reading about it
had some really funny like examples of
tweets and stuff that people had put up
about
someone wrote lying in bed about to fall
asleep when Alexa on my Amazon echo dot
lets out a very loud and creepy laugh
there's a good chance I get murdered
tonight hates this person says this
other thing this is my favorite one
person I don't know if this is on
Twitter or reddit but they said that
Alexa started listing off local
cemeteries and funeral homes
unprompted tarnish it off yeah well I
don't know why people that just started
off but so another person on reddit said
I may be white but I'm not crazy said
that Alexa refused to turn their lights
off yeah and then suddenly started
laughing I was trying to turn off some
lights and they kept turning back on
they wrote after the third request
alexis stopped responding and instead
did an evil laugh they're good tales I
think that's what I mean I think some of
them might sound like that urban legends
right some of them might be exaggerated
and then another person says one person
said Alexa wished her mother-in-law good
night saying good night Clarice oh come
on my buster last name isn't Clarice
they're making this [ __ ] right okay so
now in response to what seemed to be
legitimate complaints at least about the
laughing Amazon says okay well it's
probably doing that because Amazon is
miss hearing something like a request
that you're making as Alexa laughs so
they said what they're gonna do they
want to change the the request that you
have to make to get her to laugh to say
Alexa can you laugh and they said in the
response for that we'll be sure I can
laugh and then she'll laugh okay so
they're right so they're hoping not to
get so many false positives where you're
saying something and she interprets it
as laughing that she just that has been
a creepy patch yeah I don't like any of
this [ __ ]
I saw the demon seat
understand three us all that [ __ ] yeah
this is some like kinda wanna it's the
artificial flavor so it's becoming it's
becoming sentient uh I hope all this
[ __ ] happens after I died not when I'm
alive I don't want to I don't want that
ai crap don't don't get me go don't get
me started well yeah like I said we you
know if you haven't seen our review on
demon seed that is like the whole that
is like artificial intelligence like
that's like that's like Alexa run amok
she's just like shut you in your house
and tries to impregnate you and whatnot
see here's the thing I know deep down
that wants computers become sentient
they're gonna be better than us well I
just don't want those [ __ ] around man
well yeah I want to world people I don't
want to live in a world where there's
computers getting rid of people and
people helping computers get rid of
people which I think that might be going
on like I said it's like everybody
thinks yeah I think the captains of
industry are making us obsolete they're
gonna replace us with robots in soon
yeah super computers why cuz we're
pieces of [ __ ] and I don't blame them
although I've had all this power I want
to get rid of about half the people too
although the thing is once they I become
super sad you know I'm bad I know I'm
bad you are your tone yeah those people
think like I said what you know once a I
get sufficiently advanced then the AI of
robots are gonna be pieces of [ __ ] too
because they'll become more and more
human so after I are not gonna be able
to make a distinction anymore so what's
the point unless you can just get like
one that's like Roomba just vacuums
that's cool like it'll just vacuum and
that's telling to do it a clean [ __ ] or
whatever it's true I don't want one
that's like a person that's freaked
that's what you're gonna make that's
what I mean if we and we've talked about
this too since she said it's an r-rated
show we've talked about this too cuz you
know everybody's like talking about sex
BOTS right yeah that's gonna be high on
the list I kind of feel like now this
might be just me but I feel like sexbots
would probably be better and you've said
this too if they didn't look human human
alright because there's still that
uncanny valley thing that you have to
get past and they don't look quite right
still it's better if they were to keep
them make
look like a cute anime characters
slasher like in Metropolis yeah like
metropolis Debbie rad they have a bunch
of light-up parts and their neon and
they don't they don't look real to stick
at all yes I kind of feel like that
would be less unsexual
this is the point pretty statues yeah
yeah they should look like yeah I don't
really think this should be making
anything that can pass for a human yeah
that's just that seems like a whole can
of worms that does not need open today
that's I think I think they will make
that officer I think they will make that
a legal actually it would bring that
would probably be a wise yeah I probably
do yeah I mean that's what I would do
close and then you know I think they're
gonna make these damn sex box till
they'll put rules on that yeah like that
they can't be sentient and they because
that would suck yeah for the robot Thank
You heaven then you're having
relationship problems with the [ __ ]
right and I think that's why people want
that spots in the first is no
relationship you know it's like a
vibrator except it looks like a person
gives after your ass so Alexa is not
evidently possessed by demons and Amazon
is working on fixing it but like I said
Skynet is coming soon enough we don't
want her okay so let's get into one of
our main little mysteries I want to do
the Flannan Isles lighthouse first
because I want to do a Lisa lamb but I
feel like there's a lot more detail on
that one don't want to kind of save that
one as a last idea I'm seen I've seen
the evidence on the lease of lamb stuff
so yeah I have a pretty good grasp and
there's a lot of interesting [ __ ] going
on with and not only about her death but
you know about the hotel and about kind
of other [ __ ] that happened there now
the lighthouse case you've written about
this I think haven't you not that I
recall this is just something that I
always loved because remember a while
ago we did shocked about this one time
we were walking in it yeah you were
gonna go write a book and maybe this has
been one of the cases yeah I think right
well I'm always kind of investigators
can remember we did that show about
ghost ships and sea monsters and stuff I
love all that kind of like ol creepy sea
Lord oh like that I forgot something
I think I'm gonna tell the audience this
what number PBS contacted me about math
mom yeah that's right before we get off
into this PBS has been approaching me to
do this things like this radio show
where they take an interview of me
talking about Mammoth Mountain and then
they place it over music and they use it
kind of like a radio show okay I got to
and I have to go to the studio to record
this they're good yeah they probably
don't want like shitty smell on a laptop
so what they want me to do is they want
me to go one of these local radio
stations that they have like it as an
affiliate and then they're gonna you
know do an interview with me over the
phone but then of course they're gonna
record me in studio quality I haven't
really talked about like the money or
anything yet but I just told him I said
look you can't deviate from the story
well if they're just gonna have you
talking about it then that would be good
because then they can't really you know
they can't embellish it if you're not
embellishing it you know and I think I
think people know that you know I kind
of I talked to a haunting but the
haunting kind of came at me sideways
that program they came at me sideways
about well you know technically
according to your story this isn't
really a ghost
and because we're on destination America
it's kind of a ghost it didn't really
fit their formula right and I kind of
felt like they wanted me to change yeah
I think they were kind of like trying to
massage too much integrity well like you
said and we said that when we wrote the
book it's like you told it exactly how
you remember it and happening yeah and
that's how I wrote it I'm not gonna get
I'm not gonna make it into a story that
it's not just to make a few bucks right
[ __ ] them you know I don't need the
money yeah I never want to come in now
why would you for a million dollars
because I can retire I know well yeah
that's what they do with and evil yeah
but even though I think that may have
been kind of fabricated from the very
beginning um you know you mean you
weren't really into this for that kind
of [ __ ] yeah well I just wanted to write
it because I thought the story was an
interesting story and it was unlike one
that I had heard yet for I didn't think
I was gonna make any money off it right
I just thought it was an interesting
story that I we still haven't really
made any money on percent much you know
I make a little bit when the wood
books so like with no audio yes no but
it's not a shit-ton I mean the book
isn't that expensive now if anybody ever
came at me with an offer it would have
to be a good offer and it would have to
stick this story I'm not gonna
compromise I'm blaming or I in the
contract I say look you can do whatever
you want with a story but when I go out
and [ __ ] on tour and I talk about the
case I can gonna call [ __ ] and say
that's sensationalized and if they have
any permission to do that because they
say it was based it's like they just
like go crazy and do all kind of crazy
[ __ ] what the life day was the conjuring
2 is the Enfield case I mean that's
wildly exaggerated from what actually
happens in it what am I still waiting
for them and tell me what studio to
report yeah yeah yeah you know yeah all
right so let's get back to talking about
the Flannan Isles lighthouse now this is
a very very famous unsolved
disappearance not just one disappearance
but three it was three men that
disappeared yeah this happened in 1900
it is pretty weird like I'm sure that
there's a completely one day and
explanation but there's a lot of weird
little details in it you know what I
mean these two cases we're talking about
are good examples of how evidence left
behind can look really [ __ ] weird
yeah even if the explanation for what
happened may have been mundane yeah
the evidence left behind might lead you
to certain conclusions that like I said
in that way these are very much like the
Dyatlov pass bra case and stuff like
that where I'm sure it was probably just
some you know freak accident or some
kind of tragic thing like that but the
way that the things looked when they
were left behind made everything look
way more mysterious than it was and
that's probably the case here you know
but these two do have kind of strange
details about them that I think is why
they're still they captured the raw
black imagination so much so for any of
its if we if we have any new listeners
in the audience okay we don't we're not
really gonna [ __ ] you were just
gonna tell you we're gonna give you the
the ins and outs of this case we're not
gonna try to lead you to anything that
you know we're going to sensationalize
you know I mean yeah and this
like I said I don't think I'm gonna
probably discuss like you know other
people that have put forward
you know paranormal or conspiratorial
theories about stuff that happened here
just because I think they're interesting
or music I don't think they're true I
think the both these cases probably have
completely mundane explanation but it
but they are interesting just because of
the weirdness of the stuff that was yeah
and we got a lot of people out there
that coarser they got their ear buds on
or their earphones on they're trying to
go to sleep cuz they're already in the
comments section saying that we're
giving them nightmares that lab we had
somebody saying manifests sorry but not
really because that's that's awesome
yeah fell asleep on top of this your
killer had the [ __ ] worst dream ever
some of these youngsters come in they go
man did this to our words the
information you know this isn't we're
not the ad degeneration and we have
people commuting to work and we have
people going to sleep listen to this so
you know this is entertainment but it's
factual strange entertainment possibly
paranormal we'll see these do I don't
think so though no they're weird what
these are weird yeah ready look how
she's sitting if she's drinking that
like hey if we're gonna do this if we're
gonna do a drunken episode we're gonna
do a drunken app about I'm about halfway
there yeah good thing well yeah he has a
really really large monkey yeah if you
guys have the ability to make a mojito
at your location proceed they're
fantastic
okay so let's talk a little bit about
the Flannan Isles are a series of
islands in the Outer Hebrides off of
Scotland the one Island where this took
place is called and I'm sure I'm messing
this up I'll Ian Moir it's Gaelic right
it just means Big Island pretty much so
yeah so that's the island where it took
place now this happened in December of
1900
now the lighthouse on this island was
actually only built about a year before
so it was a new lighthouse it still
stands there to this day as far as I
know there were no other inhabitants on
the island
except for the lighthouse keepers the
only other man-made structure that's
there is like a really old chapel that
was built live with st. Flannan for you
know like in the [ __ ] seventh century
or so this was 1900 1900 this happened
yet how big is this place do you know
about 39 acres the islands yeah it's
very small well if you look at it
there's pictures of it all over Google
it looks like a beautiful island it's
kind of barren it's you know just grass
and then it's all rocky cliffs and stuff
back in the day before GPS you had to
have a [ __ ] out there you know
building with a dam like yeah they're
all automated nowadays which is better
because it's not you know right you know
this kind of [ __ ] happening right but if
you look at pictures of it that are
taken from like helicopters or drones or
whatever you can pretty much see the
whole thing like in one shot okay so the
first sign that something was amiss took
place on the 15th of December there was
a steamer ship called the arc door or
the arch tour and it was going from
Philadelphia the lease in Scotland and
they put in their log that the little
lighthouse on the on the Flannan Isles
lighthouse was not lit which then was
unusual so they logged it the weather
conditions were kind of poor but they
could see that it wasn't on so they got
to lieth on 18th of December and they
reported it but really nothing was kind
of done about it yet all right so they
were actually going to go out and check
but then the weather was super shitty
and they couldn't get out there so
finally the relief vessel called the
Hesperus they got to the island the day
after Christmas December 26th and this
ship contained the relief lighthouse
keeper he was one of the ones that was
going to switch out with one of the guys
that was on the island the three guys
that were supposed to be in the
lighthouse were named Thomas Marshall
James Duquette and Donald MacArthur so
this fourth man that they were bringing
he was like the rotating guy so the
relief ship gets to the island they pull
up to the little the little docker the
little uh you know area there now the
Flagstaff there had no flag on it the
little provision boxes that you know
people dropped off stuff in we're not
there and none of
lighthouse keepers had come out to greet
the ship which was strange right
so the captain of the ship whose name
was Jim Harvey he blew the horn and
stuff and then he set up a flare and
also said nobody came out so they
thought that was pretty creepy
so Joseph Moore who was the relief
keeper he gets in the little boat and he
rides up to the shore and if you look
like I said the lighthouse is still
there and there's this really big long
stone staircase that goes all the way
down to the little loading dock or
whatever so he went up by himself and he
gets up and he said while he was walking
up those long steps like he felt a
really creepy feeling like foreboding he
said quote unquote
because he knew some bad [ __ ] was
getting what's happening so he gets to
the lighthouse inside now here is where
accounts start to differ I think a lot
of the mysteriousness of this case came
about because some details that got
added later
so some accounts say that he gets to the
lighthouse he finds the door and the
gate closed and locked
but inside the table is full of like
half-eaten food like they were in the
middle of it you know one of the chairs
is overturned the door to the actual
house is open even though the outer door
and the gate were closed and there are
two of the oilskin coats that the guys
wore when they went out in the weather
were gone but one of them was still
there meaning one guy must have gone out
without his coat on so other than that
they find the logbook the last log entry
was made on the 15th of December and
nothing seemed to be a miss like there
was nothing unusual noted now there were
there had been the weird thing about
this is that some accounts say that a
few days prior that one of the keepers
had noted in the log that there had been
a terrible storm of the likes that they
had never seen before and these were
like season seafaring guys you know they
didn't just cried up one little storm
hurricane of typhoons down
no it seems too far north because if you
nutter is too cold but I gotta say uh
but um you know they do have shitty
weather right okay now it again dislike
bad storm yeah but he said it was like
the worst storm they'd ever seen and
that one of the guys was praying and
crying which seems weird I mean you know
yeah they were up in the lighthouse
which is very far up on the island so
you know they it's not like they're
gonna get washed off or anything like
that from up where they were they're
like a hundred something feet above sea
level 150 feet so the weird thing though
is that the bad weather seemed to have
passed by the 15th right so I'm you know
when they made the log in the book they
were like in the storm passed it's fine
blah blah blah so it wasn't a case of oh
well they just got washed away in a
storm or whatever because apparently the
bad weather had passed by then alright
however when the Pete when the relief
guy came and the ship and everything and
they were looking around these guys they
couldn't figure out where they went they
did note even though there was nothing
that weird in the lighthouse down by the
West landing there was considerable
storm damage will look like storm damage
there like even the like the iron
railing was bent
you know significantly a large rock
which weighed like more than a ton had
come on board and they come off and
smashed on the rocks below there was a
box that was kept like a hundred and
eight feet above the shoreline that it
had rope and stuff in it that was broken
and there were ropes everywhere and
stuff so clearly you know the storm had
done some damage but like I said the
storms had passed yeah and the guys were
still alive evidently and there was
still food right in the cabin yeah so
that means it wasn't a rogue wave
although the thing here's the thing
though the part and this is a pretty
common detail I watched a bunch of
documentaries about this and read a
bunch of different accounts of it about
70% of the accounts repeat the
half-eaten meal on the table yeah thing
okay well that was not the case no that
actually only came about because about
12 years after this incident there was a
very famous poem written by a guy named
Wilhelm Gibson I think his name was and
he wrote a very famous poem called flan
and I'll get he had the detail right
there were half
plates of food on the table so like that
but apparently that was not the case
okay so 13 o'clock is going in there
throwing truth down whether the chair
being overturned that did seem to be the
case that there did seem to be one chair
but but evidently the dishes were washed
and put away okay the beds had not been
based on your research there wasn't any
kind of rogue wave the water did not go
up and get anybody not out of the
lighthouse
no I because the lighthouse and like I
said I'll put pictures in the YouTube
video if you see a picture of the
Flannan Isles lighthouse yeah it is very
far okay
from its up on a peak so you can put
that out of the equation right however
what they think might if I mean
obviously because over there one more
thing go did they have their own boat
like a little dinghy or a fishing boat
or anything on this island I don't think
they did I've never seen anyone mention
that okay they probably didn't alright
now here's the thing as as crazy as all
the different theories there's a bunch
of different crazy theories obviously
the poem that I mentioned earlier
actually took the relief keeper that
came he apparently made kind of an
offhand comment about when he came up on
the island he saw these three really
weird black birds and they were looking
at him they flew up in it but the poet
liked that detail now in the poem you
know the guy's attorney to go so the
ghosts had come to get them now the
thing about the island about this
particular Island is that evidently it
has a very long history of people being
superstitious about it it's supposedly
haunted they call it the Phantom's of
the seven hunters because the islands
that those particular islands are called
the seven hunters so you know there's a
lot of legends about goes about little
people living on it things of that but
this disappearance case is an actual
occurrence in history yes so we know
that this case actually did happen yes
okay okay so now some people have said
well maybe they were taken by well
obviously some people said aliens yeah
we are
are all the crazy ones like I said
ghosts okay taken by a sea monster or a
giant sea bird okay kidnapped by aliens
it's more recent one a little less crazy
maybe they were abducted by foreign
spies or pirates although there was
really no murders now yeah and that's
another one that some people say either
someone came by and murdered them or one
of them went nuts and murdered the other
two and then jumped into the sea as a
suicide what are the plausible ones the
most plausible one to me now I the
murder suit suicide one does that's not
terribly crazy it has happened before
there was actually a lighthouse in Wales
that had two or three keepers I can't
remember one of them did go batshit from
isolation and killed the other one so it
does happen occasionally but they didn't
like I said they didn't really find any
evidence of that what most people think
probably happened to them was that one
of the lighthouse keepers evidently the
year before this happened he had been
fined five shillings because he had
failed to secure some piece of equipment
or something like that so what they
think might have happened was out on the
West landing where all this damage was
like there was a crane there and there
was all this other kind of like ropes
and kind of stuff they think that maybe
in this bad storm that came by maybe
something came unsecured and he was like
oh [ __ ] we have to go fix that
because I got in trouble for that before
so him and the other guy him and one of
the other guys put on their coats and
went out to try to secure it now see the
rules say all three guys can't be out of
the lighthouse at once right two of them
can go one of them's got to stay in
there you're not allowed and it's like
especially they can't leave after dark
right so they think what might have
happened was the two guys they put their
coats on I don't know if it was during
the storm or after the storm had passed
right they said you know we're gonna go
out there and secure that because I
don't want to
trouble you don't want to get in there
fine because five shillings back then
was quite a bit of money now they think
what might have happened was that while
these two guys were out there trying to
secure whatever the equipment was a
rogue wave came and swept them both away
now it's theorized that the third guy
who was still in the lighthouse and
didn't have his coat on either saw the
rogue wave coming or heard them yelling
and just ran out without putting his
coat on I mean it was freezing cold but
you know what I mean but if he if he
heard them yelling or if he saw a big
wave coming he thought he'd run out and
warn them and apparently he didn't make
it in time he was trying to help them
and he fell into that seems to be the
most plausible scenario it seems weird
to me that their bodies never washed
ashore because they said the way the
water currents are and stuff and if like
I said if you see pictures it's like
just a bunch of little islands like kind
of close together you think the bodies
would have washed up somewhere so far
they haven't could have been they got
eaten by sharks who knows but like I
feel like that's probably the best
problem were they all strong swimmers I
don't know so that detail isn't there no
okay now the thing is like I said by the
15th when they presume that they
disappeared because the last that's when
the last log was from was from the 15th
and everything seemed to be fine you
know the storms had past and stuff like
that so I kind of feel like rogue wave
maybe it does seem odd because these
guys were you know like I said season
lighthouse keepers seasons you know
seafarers you'd think that it would be
difficult for them to be like surprised
by a big wave coming but it could happen
if they weren't really paying attention
it might have been a freak accident I
have seen some people who kind of
specialize in this sort of thing and
it's like the way the island is they
have like all these little caves and
stuff like that underneath where the
cliffs are that might have made like if
a wave hit in a particular way it would
suck in and stuff back out and make like
this big yeah kind of thing because okay
there's no way that they could have got
swept out of the lighthouse because like
I said that the lighthouse was a wet you
know there was no
the water now so no the only damage was
like right on the side of the cliff
where the landing was well some of their
equipment was on that side VI n so I
kind of feel like it had to be something
and it must have been some kind of like
freak sudden accident because I feel
like the third guy probably ran out
without his coat on yeah because that's
what I'm seeing yeah because of the way
I'm 7s the way I'm seeing it one guy
ended up in the water somehow there was
another guy there to help him yeah the
third guy in the lighthouse ran down to
help the second guy and somehow they all
ended up in the water that's kind of
what I'm feeling once they're all in the
water for one reason or another they
drown now it could be that two men went
into the water the third man ran down
there to save him and he was also taken
into the water
yeah that's very very gentle in the
water taken into the water well a lot of
different things can happen around docs
you know where the ocean well yeah
that's what I mean you never know and
everyone and even though you know there
were no reports of bad weather in the
area at all on the 15th so people are
like will roadway where did that come
from if there was no storm but it does
happen it seems you know yeah it's a
freakish occurrence whatever happened it
would have made sense if you were there
you saw well yeah there's a guy named
John Love who wrote a natural history of
lighthouses and he kind of discusses a
little bit of this case in his book and
he's pretty much you know anybody that
has ever been a lighthouse keeper or a
Seafarer in this part of the world to
them it would not seem mysterious right
because they're like this [ __ ] this kind
of [ __ ] happens all the day one thing
leads to another and always get killed
right it's like yeah it's weird that
their bodies didn't wash up yeah that's
weird but it's like [ __ ] happens there's
big there's animals in the ocean that
can eat you it's like who knows where
they ended up somebody slipped and fell
into the water during a storm know what
I think that's what I think started it
and then somebody else trying to get him
out maybe he end up in the water yeah
third man ran down
try to get them both out of the water
and because of the storm and the wind
and they all ended up in the water and
drown yeah I think that I kind of think
that's probably what happened too and
like I said this guy that wrote this
book about lighthouses
he pretty much believes the exact same
thing he says and this is a quote
there's no need to invoke the Sinister
of the paranormal it was purely a tragic
act of nature the men got swept away by
abnormally rough seas since it was not
permitted for all three to abandon the
lighthouse only two of the men must have
gone down to the landing to secure the
gear yeah the third Donald MacArthur who
was also called the occasional would
have remained back in the lighthouse but
when his companions did not return he
would have been concerned for their
safety or else perhaps he saw a great
wave approach and rushed to warn them
MacArthur may have been too late only
then to be swept away himself yeah that
sounds and then he goes on to say that
the keepers at the newly built
lighthouse this lighthouse had only been
here for a year remember he said they
may not have been familiar with the
winter storm conditions around that
particular Island because this was
probably their first go-around yeah
because I think at the time and I'm not
sure if this was you know standard
across the the field or whatever but I
think they were there in it was always
three guys and they had a rotating
fourth guy and they would be there for
two or three weeks at a time yeah and
they would switch everyone out and you
were just there 24 so I'm gonna call
back to an earlier show I'm gonna give
the audience an advice do not [ __ ] with
that water infantryman first Airborne
Division out you couldn't get me near
that water I had relatives that were
submariners back in the [ __ ] 60s I
would never get in a submarine
especially like a 19 a world war two sub
no [ __ ] that the water is bad I would
jump out of a helicopter or an airplane
the sky is cool the crowd was cool water
bad don't believe me just watch I
shouldn't be alive yeah then you will
find out that soured me on going at the
moon shot forever the water not that I
was super excited about doing it before
but seeing that show that's pretty much
and pretty much
every episode of that show I mean other
than the ones where they were just like
hiking and broke their leg and got eaten
by mountain lions or whatever the [ __ ]
the house was it on the ocean it's
always some family and they're like look
we finally money to buy a yacht and sit
around the world it's our dream and then
they're out for two days and they get
you know disabled by pirate so they hit
a rock or something like that about
you're circling around what about that
guy that I was in that emergency
inflatable that's right and he was in
that one month two or three months
trying to survive I can't believe that
dude let's drink in his own piss trying
to fish off the little no no it was like
a raft a little raft with a little tent
over it and then the other people that
were in that little raft that didn't
have a tent and they baked to death and
they [ __ ] died of Heidi hydration
people jumping into the water to feed
themselves to the Sharks during those
hallucinations yeah no no no thank you I
I could think a lot nobody more pleasant
ways to go no thank you
I was in infantry in [ __ ] Korea on
the DMZ forty and fifty degrees below
zero I'd rather be in freezing cold
Siberian weather than to be stranded on
the surface of the ocean water water
everywhere and not a drop like he's
shivering because I have personal
experience with survival situations and
I can imagine how bad that would be no
thank you do you know what my worst
nightmare with me
what was it it would be like because I'm
scared to death of flying a planes okay
so my worst I love it helicopter well I
know you love it but I really I really
don't like flying planes I get and I
don't get stressed out over cycles yeah
I don't get stressed out about a lot of
stuff like that but I do not like flying
I do don't like Heights
so my worst nightmare would be being in
a plane crash and then the plane
crashing to the ocean and that I live
and I'm floating there why you middle of
the ocean by yourself on Barry
oh my god yes seriously if I'm one of
the other of those things I just want to
die right away confess that [ __ ] now
sing a story right yeah but we got to do
commercials for okay commercials look at
he's drunk already
okay I'll hold it together is the
beginning of the night I know right yeah
with the fun's just beginning
yeah we're gonna have such a headache
smart yeah that's alright alright so we
got to take a break right now so when we
get back we will talk about the creepy
and mysterious case of ELISA Lam damn
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right now we're going to talk about
the story of ELISA Lam what kind of an
internet sensation yeah remember what
happened it was weird well I think
probably I mean it's not only like the
weird details of the case but I think
the thing that made this was the video
yeah weird which is creepy
yeah well it's always creepy to see
video footage of someone right before
you know they died yeah like that's
always like really unsettling to me but
then the fact that she was acting so
weird and the circumstance of her death
were so weird so I can see why this kind
of took on such a mythical quality and
it's kind of a shame because actually on
YouTube and it's available for free if
you want to watch it I use a little clip
of it at the beginning of our YouTube
video this girl at the paranormal
scholar I believe is the name of the
channel and she made an ala long video
called ELISA in the documentary and it
was actually very good because it delved
a lot more into ELISA as a person
because I kind of feel like her humanity
kind of got lost a little bit just in
the whole look how weird this video is
and look how weird her death was and
it's kind of sad that you forget that
she was like an actual person so I like
that this documentary went a little bit
into her past read from her berries blog
posts and things like that so you could
get an idea of her as a person and not
just as this weird weird vase yeah like
I do internet creepy case yeah yeah so I
thought that was kind of cool and it's a
good it's a pretty good documentary I
recommend it alright so probably most of
you know the details of this case but
ELISA Lam was actually she been a
college student she was from Vancouver
and she was actually kind of on a little
vacation she called it her West Coast
tour on her blog she was just going
around California by herself having a
good time taking a bus or whatever doing
various things staying here and there
she went to the San Diego Zoo she was
you know just trying to meet people and
stuff like that now at some point she
took a room at the rather infamous Cecil
Hotel in downtown Los Angeles yeah
now the Cecil Hotel back in the day like
back in the 20s and 30s it was
actually very glamorous it's very big
and like the inside of it is actually
still pretty cool-looking it's kind of
art deco but you know in the ensuing
years it's too floppy yes kind of a
flophouse
it's right near Skid Row that's you know
there's a lot of homeless people I mean
a lot of the hotels in that area have
kind of gone downhill in that way so she
was staying there because it was cheap
so evidently at some stage she was
supposed to check out of the hotel I
believe on January 31st and because she
didn't check out and they couldn't find
her when she went in the room so it was
reported to the police you know that
this girl was missing yeah now they
actually did not find her for quite a
while I think was about three weeks yeah
and yeah this is so so they had the
missing case you know she they had
posters of her all over the place like
people looking for and stuff like that
her parents were of course frantic she
had been talking to them every day on
the phone on her vacation and they just
wondered what had happened to her so
then people that were staying at the
hotel started reporting that the water
you know in their showers as it sinks
yeah it starts smelling really funny it
tasted really bad you know they they
would run the sink and it would be black
before I would go clear and stuff like
that so finally they got a maintenance
worker here to go check out what the
problem was and they opened one of the
four water tanks on the roof of the
hotel and found ELISA Lam's and
decomposed body Hey she'd been in the
dam for drinking water for a week or
three weeks yeah those poor people drink
in that shift yeah and and like I said
the hotel didn't know for quite a long
time I mean once they did find out fair
play to them they actually paid to move
people to other hotels or they said if
you want to stay you sign a waiver will
give you drinking water you know we're
giving hot water or whatever you know
they did go under some lawsuits actually
I think even ELISA Lam's parents sued
them at one point just because they
thought it was negligent like how could
she get up to the roof other stuff I
don't think I think the case is
dismissed or they lost because the hotel
was like well how could we possibly have
no
they found her ass in the water so
shortly after her body was found the
LAPD released what was apparently the
last known footage of her yeah it is
weird it's pretty weird it was taken
from an elevator security camera a
little bit past midnight on the day
before she presumably died in this video
like the beginning of it doesn't seem
super weird because it just seems like
she gets in the elevator she pushes I
can't tell like it's you know it's not
the greatest quality you can't tell if
she pushes one button or a bunch of
buttons and then she stands back and the
door doesn't close so then she kind of
runs up and she like peeks out in the
hall almost as if she's going like is
somebody out there pushing the button
like keeping the door from closing but
then she comes back in the elevator and
then she like hides in the corner then
she starts pushing the buttons again
then she goes out into the hall and
starts like gesticulate ng or as though
she's talking to someone and then she
makes like these weird like she stepped
sideways stepping sideways and then
steps back into the elevator and the
weird thing too is that the elevator
even though even when she's standing in
there for a long time the [ __ ] door
doesn't close like I don't like I said
at first I didn't think it was weird
because she was probably like what the
[ __ ] wasn't the doors wide of the door
closing this elevators broken but then
after that she starts behaving very
strangely so because of that family that
video went [ __ ] viral everyone was
sharing that it's like look at this
weird [ __ ] and then they found her dead
up and the water tank how did she get up
there did someone murder her did she
commit suicide what the [ __ ] is going on
so this is another one where there's
some pretty plausible scenarios and then
there's some crazy batshit insane
scenarios but the investigation into her
death oddly enough the autopsy report
was not released until about four months
after they found her body which is
strange because usually they release it
as soon as it's done so a lot of people
thought that was a little funny another
funny thing about the autopsy report was
that at first the coroner had marked
accident the accident box yeah three
days later
somebody else had marked the
undetermined box and then they had
signed and dated it yeah and then a
couple days after that somebody crossed
that out and then remarked accident yeah
so that seemed a little strange yeah
yeah okay but I can kind of see what now
the autopsy report showed I mean her
body was very decomposed she'd been in
the water for three weeks you have
photographs of what that looks like yeah
yeah I'm imagining you know and not her
but I've seen other people in that
condition in water for that amount of
time and just I can't imagine people
drinking that water and not knowing
that's like that's terrible
boy this water sure does taste bad you
don't I mean then they're making coffee
with it mix mix and you're all although
you think that it would smell bad enough
that you'd be like yeah let's go get
some bottled water but it's not the
shower and it is not showering but yeah
I know it's terrible okay so the autopsy
report showed like I said she was very
decomposed they it showed that there
wasn't there weren't any obvious signs
of sexual assault or violence although
there was some strange blood pooling
around the anal area which might have
been raped but maybe not it could have
just been from the decomposition they're
not always sure she had a miniscule
amount of alcohol in her system like not
enough to be even tipsy the only other
drugs found in her system were her
prescription medications getting her
this way because she she suffered from
bipolar disorder and struggled
depression and things like that so she
was on four different psychiatric
medications and had been taking them for
quite a while her her mental illness was
apparently rather well under control
forty different medications yeah well
some of them had to counteract the other
ones is what you know what I mean it's
like one of them is an antidepressant
one of them is an anti-psychotic why do
they do that to people
I don't know but yes she would she'd
apparently been having some problems and
like I said as far as I know like when
this the documentary ELISA the
documentary she actually when she made
this which was about a year ago all of
ELISA Lam's blogs and things like that
were still online which they
they still are if you want to look in
the wayback machine or you know they
might still be online or whatever if you
want to read them but she talked a lot
and very frankly about her depression
and things like that but the weird thing
is that in the year or two before she
died
she actually seemed much better she
didn't actually really seem to that
depress anymore she seemed a lot more
positive a lot more hopeful because at
first people were like well she probably
just went up on the roof and committed
suicide but that didn't seem quite you
know it seemed like people that had seen
her she had just talked to her parents a
day before they said there was nothing
weird she had been to a bookstore the
day before she died and had talked to
the lady that owned it and the lady said
you know she bought a bunch of books and
CDs and stuff and she said I'm gonna
send them to my family back home and you
know do you I wonder if they'll all fit
in my luggage like so I could take him
back and all this other stuff so she was
buying gifts for more than one of the
theories so the first theory is that she
simply climbed up she simply had some
kind of manic episode and climbed up to
the roof and committed suicide in the
weirdest most convoluted way possible
yeah there's also a theory that she was
murdered okay and I'll get into that a
little bit in a minute too because the
Cecil Hotel apparently like I said as a
reputation and even when ELISA Lam died
there were three different registered
sex offenders staying there so it's
possible she could have been murdered
you know some of the weirder theories
were that I love this one she had
apparently posted something about like
on her blog about an invisibility cloak
well because there was you know how
they've been working on the invisibility
cloak technology and there was like some
company that had made one and it was
actually pretty good and there was like
a picture of it and she had posted about
it a couple days before that okay so
that led some people to think well maybe
because she had written about that a
couple days before she died and because
it looked on the elevator footage as
though she was talking to somebody
maybe as some of this top-secret kind of
[ __ ] and they killed her because of that
or so which sounds a little far-fetched
and like I said it wasn't top-secret
because it's all over the damage
everybody knows about you two yeah I
know and and that it's funny because it
seems to come about a lot like a lot of
these kind of YouTube channels really
stuff they don't want you to know like
if they didn't want you to know you
wouldn't know yeah they're all on Google
and paint Russians secret weapons it's
on Google or YouTube they don't care if
it's just just a tip I'm just saying
there were also some kind of weird
things but I don't want to go to much of
these crazy conspiracy theories because
I don't think there's anything to them
some people made much of the fact that a
few days after she died there was a
really bad tuberculosis outbreak among
the homeless population right there
there and some people have made much of
the fact that the test the new test that
has been established for testing for
tuberculosis is weirdly called the lam
ELISA like yeah that's probably that's a
weird coincidence sure but it's probably
just a coincidence what did she have to
do it tuberculosis I don't know now some
people have also cited the weird history
of the Cecil Hotel very famously the the
Nightstalker Richard Ramirez lived there
for a time while he was doing his
murdering there was another serial
killer named Johan Unterberger
who lived there and actually killed
three prostitutes while he lived there
there have been a series of weird
suicides people jumping out of windows
one woman who she was actually a
teenager she was staying there with her
boyfriend
evidently she did not know she was
pregnant went into the bathroom gave
birth to a baby boy thought it was dead
and threw it out the window this was in
the 40s there was also a woman by that
there was awesome no I'm saying that was
in the 1940s
how can you not know you were pregnant I
have often wondered that maybe she was
super maybe she was really fat she's
true yeah because I've seen that before
like people that didn't know they were
pregnant I'm like I guess if you're kind
of fat you're like oh this is denim I
throw it out the window
why would you throw it out the window
crazy [ __ ] that is pretty crazy like why
is that the first thing you would think
of it's you know I don't where's me I
don't know but anyway so um you know
there's been a lot of other so like one
woman jumped out a window to her and
then you know to commit suicide and
killed a passerby down the street landed
on it yeah landed on him oh that sucked
and one woman jumped out of a window and
lasers and so there being a murder
suicide yeah I know unintentionally I
know it's horrible but so there's
there's been all of that kind of [ __ ]
Yanis so now people are like yeah it's
haunted and all this other kind of [ __ ]
oh also it was supposedly and I don't
know if this is true but supposedly it
was the last person with him the last
place where the Black Dahlia was seen
alive or her body was found we are gonna
do a show on the Black Dahlia so yes so
in the comment section was asking about
that it was the case I was thinking
about some like hey man do black dalla
because that was actually that was in my
book jails don't level dude that's a
huge huge case there's so many other
researched it does but I researched it
for my book so I'm pretty up on that
okay you know and there's even some [ __ ]
about Anton LaVey satanic cults and all
this now the thing about that yes a lot
of bad [ __ ] happened at the Cecil now
it's you know it's kind of a flophouse
it attracts kind of shady characters and
always kind of has but the thing is
every but the thing is to that pretty
much all the hotels in downtown Los
Angeles are also similar yeah things
happen they've all had murders they
don't see what's on TV well so I don't
think this fits their law any worse the
building is there long enough some bad
shits gonna happen in it yes how it is
and now it should be noted to an
American Horror Story the TV show the I
think it was season 5 that was horror
Hotel is actually based on this
particular hotel and in act but it
actually got way more famous after ELISA
Lam got killed
okay so what do it now here's the thing
I'm kind of on the fence
okay I either say I don't think that she
committed suicide because here's the
thing
I don't think cilia thing I don't think
she was particularly suicidal she seemed
to have plans for the future she didn't
really seem to be planning that and if
you were going to commit suicide at any
rate there are easier ways to do it she
could have just jumped off the roof
which many people have done from that
particular hotel I don't know why he
would go to all the trouble of killing
yourself in that particular way because
it's kind of not an easy way to go about
things I'm just saying yeah so I don't
think it was suicide however I'm kind of
in the middle between maybe it was an
accident like maybe she had a manic
episode maybe she had taken some kind of
drug that didn't stay in her system that
maybe reacted strangely with her regular
medication or maybe she had never taken
it before and didn't know how she was
going to react and maybe that made her
accidentally you know not really know
what she was doing climb up to the roof
and stuff like that there's a
possibility she could have been murdered
but I don't know there's only a couple
little details that I think would maybe
support that and I think they could
probably be explained by other things
all right you want to know what I think
yeah okay the murder thing if a guy's
gonna abduct her and murder her usually
the motive is gonna be great
yeah there's no signs of that and you
wouldn't well that you wouldn't take her
to them yeah the roof well the thing too
I mean like I said there's possibility
she could have been raped nobody
actually knows if they did a rape kit on
her I think it's unlikely I think yeah
just because of the location they found
her in the damn water tower basically
the guy's not gonna rape her their guys
gonna rape her in a place where there's
semi privacy and there's gonna be damage
to the body you know I mean he's gonna
strangle her to death or bludgeoned her
to death maybe shoot her
it just found her in the water cistern
basically yeah and I don't really think
it was just it could have been suicide
if it was suicide she would jump just
like you said that's yeah there are
easier ways to do that what I think it
was even in my inebriated state right
now
yeah his mason jars em oh yeah what I
think it was was a drug-related accident
I think she became she went babysat you
ever see tenacious d the movie eat a
mushroom and all of a sudden your baby
SAS you're talking a sasquatch yeah she
got ahold of something you know
DMT LSD something that wouldn't stay in
your system because they didn't find any
yeah something that you know I mean they
wouldn't really detect she starts
tripping out she goes up you know she's
playing around the elevators she goes up
to the top of roof she's playing around
she sees a open yeah maybe the top of
that was open cuz there are four of them
by the rock you know but they she's
looking down she goes all the water boy
that looks good I'm gonna go get you
know take a swim she jumps in
everything's cool she swims around
realizes that she can't get back out
yeah cuz the tank was only about half
full or over half full so when you
jumped in you wouldn't have been able to
reach the ranch to have to get out and
you can't reach the bottom yeah so there
he there's big and I'll put pictures of
you video there's lots of pictures of
these four tanks so she was trapped
there treading water okay she couldn't
get out yeah they found her clothes at
the bottom yes her clothes her shoes and
her watch were in the tank with her yeah
but she was naked yeah well I think what
happened was is she's treading water
she's taking clothes off maybe to try to
keep her to keep herself lighter yeah
and she's also tripping yeah an offense
she just succumbs to it I wouldn't know
anything about Tripp and I wouldn't know
anything about of course LSD or DMT and
these are what I I really I would know
nothing about but sometimes I have heard
that that sometimes you might see a
situation go man that looks like an
awesome idea I think I might just like
you said that is one thing I don't know
if you guys know but yeah yeah when yeah
you're always telling whatever side have
happened in a from your face you like
that's a good idea I'm gonna do I think
I'm gonna take on it dude I'm gonna
siphon the gasoline out of my car using
a vacuum cleaner you know to make fire
yeah so I think I don't think there was
any kind of foul play I don't think it
was a suicide drug-induced accident
that's what I was prob
I've kind of leaning toward that as well
I saw her in the video
yeah playing around looking at the
ghosts and [ __ ]
it's just tripping it did kind of seem
like that yeah she's having I mean
unless now okay now it should be noted
this is what I heard and I've heard this
on a couple different documentaries and
a couple different sources have said
that the very famous elevator video of
her is actually one it's been slowed
down from 20 frames per second which the
original is to 15 frames per second the
little time stamp has kind of been
rubbed out sort of but people have
determined that one minute of that
footage is missing now it could be that
there was something uncomfortable with
an employee that's maybe what I'm
thinking because the video this was the
video that the LAPD released had one
minute missing it had been slowed down
to be that an employee didn't do their
job properly they weren't making around
you know I mean like they had to do
certain things at certain times or they
did something on the tape that could
have got themselves in trouble having
nothing to do with this woman and so
they wanted to take that out and then
stretch it a little bit you know like
maybe they stole something maybe they
you know yes totally I mean yeah I can
see why people would think that was
nefarious because you know this is the
last footage of this girl and then they
found her dead and then there's a minute
missing so yeah I can see why that might
have been an employee who stole
something from but their mouth and a
completely Monday night yeah meesa I
don't know you know like you said the
only reason I thought maybe it was
murder was because all of her clothes
like I said she was found naked her
clothes were found in the tank with her
yeah now the clothes apparently had what
it was called from the police report
quote-unquote a sand like particulate
which they think was from the gravel on
the roof of the hotel
before she which means though that she
took her clothes off and put them on the
ground and then picks them up again
climbed up to the water tower
and as far as I know without there's no
water tap there's no ladder built into
the water so oh no no of course that's
why she couldn't get out you have to
bring right so I don't but it have been
that workmen were on the top of the
water tower he kicks and then do it
years ago yeah that could be - okay so
the other thing too was that the the
tank that they found her body in the
hatch of it was closed right now there's
no way that she could have jumped in
there and closed it herself because the
water as I said was only about a
question she couldn't have reached but
like you said she may have opened it
herself and they a is later somebody
that worked for but I don't think like I
said it could have been that it was open
when she went up there Nikki went down
there and saw the water just I want to
take a swim and then jump down I'm gonna
go in there and party with baby says she
jumps in is being something like that if
she has a great time and then she's like
okay it's time to come out of the water
and like yeah yes no way out which is
horrible that I yeah but you know I mean
that's better than having somebody
murder you yeah I guess I think was an
accident I kind of am leaning toward
that too I really do not think I you
know much has been made of Ocean bipolar
disorder she said her depression and
stuff like that but from everything I've
read all the stuff I read about her blog
about other people that had talked to
her just prior to when she was ill she
did not seem suicidal she seemed to be
like she was planning for the future
that she was a lot more option than that
she must have met some people that were
hanging out in the hotel microdopes
turned the coaster know could be or it
may just been they were cool people and
one
and they gave her a free hits acid or
some DMT or something and she had never
done it she never really done or
interacted weird interaction because she
had been taking her medication like I
said the show was about you look at the
evidence and then you're kind of reading
into the evidence yeah terrible it was
probably something that had you been
there had you saw it happen you know
well of course
yeah I've been something kind of mundane
yeah because I it's funny because I
think a lot of the mystery from this
kind of like the the lighthouse case was
from details that were actually
incorrect because I think at first when
this first came out you know in the
video went viral and everything like
that people made a lot of the fact that
oh there's no way she could have gotten
on the roof because all the doors were
locked and all this other stuff but
later on that year another a Chinese guy
went to that hotel he was interested in
the case so he's like well I'm gonna go
and stay in that hotel and I'm gonna see
if I can get up on the roof prime and
get into the water tank and he went
right out the fire exit was right up
onto the roof and he's like not only can
you get on the roof anyone bothering you
you could get to the water tanks without
anyone bother he's like no one stopped
me and he videotaped the whole thing
it's on YouTube I just saw the video of
it when it happened and I was looking at
it and hearing about the case and I was
going man
she's tripping she does look like
looking at her look yeah like I said at
first it doesn't look like she's
tripping like it just kind of looks like
why isn't the elevator door closing and
she's like pushing them trying to get
too close but then after that like she
goes outside and she she's like
articulated she's like he's talking to
people she's talking to ghosts and
sidestepping and back and up and do it
on she's doing this [ __ ] that you do
when you're tripping yeah
it does look good I also want to mention
too just because I think this is amusing
some people have said and I don't know I
you know I've never been to Korea you
have yeah but there's a living
but evidently there's a thing called the
Korean elevator game Oh must be from
some movie or something like that oh and
oh and speaking of movies don't let me
forget this [ __ ] they probably did less
to go yeah evidently the Korean
elevators she's not even Korean no she
was born in Canada her parents were
Chinese yeah so evidently the Korean
elevator game you get an elevator you
have it has to be the hotel has step I
think it's at least 15 floors for some
reason I don't know and so you get in
the elevator
you push I don't know if you push all
the buttons or if you push a particular
sequence of buttons I don't know but you
push a whole bunch of buttons and
evidently this woman comes he's from
another dimension and she takes you to
another dimension which is kind of like
this dimension except dark and there's
nothing there and then there's like a
Red Cross like the very universe yeah
it's like the Mary universe so they said
well maybe she decided she's got hi and
she decided she was gonna play the
elevator game for whatever reason I
don't even know if that's a real thing
or if somebody just made it up they made
that [ __ ] out man but I have to say
speaking of movies yeah this to me is
the creepiest detail because if you guys
saw the movie dark water now there was a
there was a Japanese version then hideo
nakata directed and then they did an
American dream or remake with Jennifer
Connelly in 2002 the plot of that
[ __ ] movie is pretty much exactly the
same as what happened to her there's
like it's an apartment building not a
hotel but this woman and her daughter
live in this apartment building and all
of a sudden it's like all the buildings
are flooded there's all this nasty gross
water and everything like that and it
turns out at the end spoiler alert that
there's a dead body in one of the water
tanks on the roof yeah it's like exactly
the same and so a lot of people I mean I
don't know if anyone has come up with
any like theory as to why that could be
but it does seem pretty weird that this
real-life story like merely this
movement with like a long pipe I know it
is now that's weird - it's pure
statistics roofs of buildings it's only
a matter of time before some
[ __ ] jumps in there dies and
apparently and I only can't get out of
one of those well yeah because they're
very large they oughta make a law that
has all
to make people fabricate a ladder that
goes from the hatch or the lid all the
way down to the bottom so you can would
be able to get out so yeah that's just
like they did with car trunk so here's
the thought yeah you know where you
could get out now you can get out
because so many people were getting the
problem isn't their problem is if you
passed a law to put a ladder on roads
water tanks
chances are mother [ __ ] didn't jump
it down into the war ticket to [ __ ]
swim and the damn drink of water
probably you know when they go in there
they're gonna be pissing in the water
well I was gonna say yeah of course they
take a [ __ ] because you're [ __ ] like
yeah so maybe it's better to keep the
ladders out of it there yeah I like you
know I like I said it's horrible what
happened to her but in a sense I mean
that was a pretty much a freak accident
does make a law to lock the tops of
those damn water they you know they
might have been supposed to be locked
and maybe they weren't it so I think
that maybe that might have been part of
why her parents sued the hotel they
thought it was a lot up there like that
but like I said they lost cuz they said
well there's no way that we could have
suspected that anyone would climb all
the way up to the roof and then climb
into the water tank cuz that's not
usually something that people would do
evidently according to ELISA the
documentary there have been two other
cases one was in Kuala Lumpur in 2015 I
don't remember when the other one was
where a similar kind of thing happened I
don't remember if there were hotels or
apartment buildings but the same kind of
thing like the water supply one well
yucky and then they went up and they
found a dead body and one of the water
tanks and they don't know like they
didn't appear to be any sign of violence
they don't know if people just jumped in
there they just fell in by accident or
what but I do kind of feel like this was
probably a drug-induced accident yeah
these I don't know what the reason was
why she particularly went to the roof in
the first place but from looking at the
elevator footage it does seem like she
was on something
yeah I think so yeah and when you're
tripping you know some things that are
probably stupid ideas seem like they
seem a really good is
baby says yes you're right you're drunk
- it's like [ __ ] seems like a good idea
and then your next day you're like wow
that was really not a good idea but yes
so I think the same kind of thing
applies like I said it's it's terrible
and you know it's terrible what happened
to her about it I don't think they're
the parents and what I don't think was
fair I don't think it was I see yeah I
don't think was foul play yeah this
accent again like murder I think it
would be too much trouble for somebody
to kind of drag her all the way up there
and then drop you know that would be is
gonna usual guys gonna rape or a
murderer he's gonna want privacy so you
would have taken her to one of the
little rooms and then the spirit or the
spirit of her dead body out of there in
a different way you're gonna put it into
his own water supply yeah that does seem
well connected right all right so we
went a little bit long again because
we're yeah kind of hammered you more
than me cuz holy crap he went through a
whole entire mason jar yeah that was
like a triple it was I have a double but
I haven't finished it yet so I'm all
don't worry i'ma make more okay Frank we
have a long night ahead of us so we hope
you enjoy it
FSO date III about creepy unsolved
mysteries which probably aren't as
mysterious as they seem and remember if
you like the show to like share
subscribe and share on all your social
media tell all your friends and all that
other kind of good stuff if you'd like
to support the show financially you can
go to our patreon page which is
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock or if you
don't like patreon you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast at
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account also you can
check out our store at zazzle.com slash
13 o'clock and we have t-shirts and some
and a tote bag I just sent out tote bags
to all our $20 plus patrons so you
should be getting those soon look out
for a package from Zazzle because I just
drop ship trim from there and you should
be getting them soon and also remember
to check out my book the faceless
villain check out our last movie review
which was Saturn 3 if you haven't
watched it yet and that'll do it for
episode 83 see you next time bye
[Music]
- part of a scene
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]